story armenia's president has demanded
the prime minister quit
and immediate parliamentary elections
mass rallies are calling the peace deal
with azerbaijan over disputed region
nagorno-karabakh
humiliating rt zelia petrenko joined me
in the studio to discuss the aftermath
of the ceasefire
this is the moment when the whole
political career
of armenian prime minister negotiates
being put to the test
so the pm may end up getting
even stronger than he used to be and
survive as the head of government or
he could lose everything that he won in
2018 that was only
two years ago when during a revolution
he kicked the old government
out as a result of a popular uprising
and came to power
so nicole pashanyan used to enjoy
enormous public
support then came the war though after
weeks
of intense battles nicole passing young
had to sign
a peace agreement which meant that the
pro-armenian enclave would lose about a
half
of the territory that it used to control
and then the mood in yerevan
and around the country changed people
came out to the streets chanting
passion get out and that was the time
when the president who at the moment has
less powers than the prime minister
still though
he decided to come out make part of it
we lost the war
imposed on us both on the battlefield
and in diplomatic and international
platforms
you can lose a battle but it's
unacceptable to lose
as a nation we have a concerned society
and a damaged economy that is burdened
with massive social issues
it is obvious that in order to avoid
internal political
upheaval holding early parliamentary
elections
is inevitable just to give you a picture
of
the level of fury and division
the scale of unrest i want to show you
the pictures that
we received almost straight after the
peace agreement which came into being
thanks to russia
was signed
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
so in the course of that war escalation
it was becoming increasingly clear that
azerbaijan and its troops
are gaining ground taking more and more
land so prime minister
nicole pashanyan is justifying his move
by
saying that he had no other choice and
that he managed
at least to save some land for the
armenian community in nagorno-karabakh
there is no doubt for me that i am the
main official responsible for what's
happened
that i am responsible in the context of
what happened there are no discrepancies
here i am aware
as before that in this case roughly
speaking
i must be brought to justice by the
people but in order for the people to be
judges
they must have the information about all
the circumstances
so how's the whole situation with the
peace deal and the aftermath being seen
in azerbaijan
the leadership and the people in
azerbaijan are celebrating and they're
treating this
as victory in fact november the 10th is
now known in azerbaijan as the new
victory day
however many troops of the azerbaijan
army
lost their lives on the front line and
the war left
enormous scars inside and outside the
conflict zone and that includes
azerbaijani cities and towns as well and
this is what
president of azerbaijan and ham aliyev
reminded us
in one of his latest statements the
enemy has destroyed all the
infrastructure
they will be held accountable for
everything they have done in the
international court
i said this earlier and i want to repeat
once again
that international structures and
experts will be involved
all the damage will be evaluated and we
will be demanding compensation for the
last 30 years
devastation heavy damage and enormous
numbers of casualties
on both sides but despite the rhetoric
that we heard from the azerbaijani
leader
baku is promising to treat the ethnic
armenians
like neighbors without any
discrimination in the territories that
are now being handed over
to baku and that were previously
controlled by
the armenian side but of course the war
left many scars like i said and
the wounds are not going to heal for a
very long time
for decades maybe for even centuries so
definitely we'll hear
about this conflict we'll keep on
hearing about it for a very long time
to remind you under the peace deal both
sides will hold on to their current
military positions now that gives
armenia control of the disputed region's
capital stepanakat azerbaijan gets the
second largest city
shushi which it took just before the
fighting ended
armenia will also have to hand over
three other districts in the region
analyst alessandro bruno says the public
outcry in armenia
over the truce is hardly surprising
this is not going to be a very easy
situation even if elections are called
quickly and i believe the president's
hope for a government of national unity
that may be too much of a hope this war
was entered into without the
proper calculations it was a losing
proposition from the start and in fact
everything went against the armenian
side so it was important to stop this
soon
and i think pashanyan must be
at least praised for stopping the
conflict before
things got out of hand but it was
predictable that
this would happen the the anger
politically obviously if you entered
into a war like this that means you
haven't delivered what you promised when
you came into power
well this is footage of russian military
equipment heading to the karabakh
region the peacekeeping mission will
include special vehicles as well as
demining units
the patrols will monitor the ceasefire
and help the rebuilding process
after the war the head of the red cross
international committee has already
expressed gratitude to the peacekeepers
we got reaction on the streets of the
armenian capital yerevan
it's good that there's peace they're
building roads providing security this
is excellent
i welcome the fact that peacemakers are
in karabakh
it is better than losing it all together
the earlier the help comes the better
even better if they had come before we
suffered all these losses
armenians and russians are brotherly
people the role of the russian
peacekeepers here is especially
important